David Arquette hospitalized after a
wrestling death match he took to Twitter
to explain his hospitalization and
address graphic video and photos of his
injury that surfaced after the match he
wrote quote the main reason I got
injured was because of my lack of
experience don't try this at home
he added I knew it was violent and
potentially bloody but I truly did not
know the extent of what I was
participating in our Kent goes on to
take full responsibility for his
injuries and apologizes for any negative
attention the incident has brought to
the sport he adds he is looking forward
to getting back into the ring under much
different circumstances in the near
future a death match is a type of
hardcore wrestling in which objects and
weapons like fluorescent light tubes are
incorporated into the fight immediately
after the match Arquette tweeted turns
out death matches aren't my thing these
wrestlers are serious pros this is just
something I'm dabbling in having a
little fun they teach me certain moves
and how to protect myself but you know
no I'll leave the real wrestling of the
professional they don't want to see some
you know soft actor you're gonna toss
around Arquette has long been a
passionate fan of the sport ET tagged
along with our cat to a wrestling match
back in 2000 well I'm getting in the
ring it's a been a dream of mine
after doing ready to run boy I really
like you know I've just ignited this you
know passion for wrestling and it's just
been so much fun and working with people
who like DDP and all these guys just
seemed like a neat opportunity